[Music]
this riddle is presented to us in the
form of an image and we need to find the
height of the table stand it's adapted
from a problem asked to elementary
school students in China the same three
things are given to us in two different
situations in the first situation the
cat is on the stand and the dog is
resting on the floor the distance from
the dog's back to the cat's head is 150
centimeters in this second situation
that dog is on the stand and the cat is
on the floor and the distance from the
cat's head to the dog's back is 120
centimeters with this odd information
how will you find the height of the
stand there are two ways to solve this
riddle but before we analyze this riddle
I want to give you some good news two
lucky winners stand a chance to win
giveaways from us and there are clues in
the video which will help you qualify
for the giveaways keep watching
this riddle video and the giveaways are
made possible because of puzzle master
which is a distributor of puzzles brain
teasers jigsaws and many more things
which help us with analytical thinking
they have some really interesting
puzzles on their website which you can
visit using the link in the description
below and hey they ship the puzzles
worldwide so here's your first clue you
need to find that country Buzzle master
is based in keep watching the video to
know how this clue can be used first
let's understand a simple and logical
way to solve it as there are three
things involved we can use three
variables for the heights let the
heights of the stand the standing cat
and the seated dog bs C and D
respectively now look at the first
situation which is on the Left using
simple math we can say that the height
of
stant plus the height of the cat minus
the height of the dog will be equal to
150 centimeters mathematically we can
write it as s plus C minus D is equal to
150 similarly can you write an equation
for the second situation we can say that
s plus D minus C is equal to 120 can we
find s using just these two equations of
course we can we just have to add them C
and negative C cancel out and D and
negative D cancel out what we have on
the left hand side is 2 times s on the
right hand side we have the sum of 150
and 120 which is 270 now dividing both
sides by 2 will give us the value of s
as 135 centimeters that's the height of
the stand well done to those who got the
correct answer and now this is your
second clue
keep watching to know how you can use
the first two clues there's also a
visual way to solve the riddle all we
need to do is place one table on top of
the other like this notice that this
length is C unit and this length is also
C units it means we can get these
lengths down by C units what if we move
both these lengths down together by C
units this is how it will look what does
this give us now it tells us that the
sum of the heights of the tables is
equal to the sum of these two lengths so
2 times s will be equal to 270
centimeters and that would give us the
value of s as 135 centimeters the visual
way was much faster right absolutely and
that brings me to the third clue for
which you'd need to know the date on
which you're watching this video so
if the date on which you are watching
this video is ninth January 2019 then
your third clue will be 1 9 0 1 0 9
which is the year month date format so
how do you use these three clues to
stand a chance to win all you need to do
is comment below in the following format
so if you think puzzle master is based
in Japan and you're watching the video
on the 9th of January in 2019 in your
country your comment should look like
this
I wish you all the best this competition
will continue for two weeks post the
launch of this video post the
competition you could just comment for
fun also we had a request for you guys
if you think this puzzle was interesting
please share this video with your
friends and family it will really help
but don't memorize YouTube channel
growth we've really looking forward to
feeding your answers
[Music]